what does it take to be an Academy Award
nominated director the heart of a
dreamer the minds of a writer the
willingness to take risks the resilience
to overcome obstacles both real and
imagined a love of all movies and an
unwavering vision of what the films
could be simply put that perfectly
describes the nominees for achievement
in directing Denis Villeneuve arrival
Mel Gibson
Hacksaw Ridge Damien Chazelle lala land
Kenneth Lonergan Manchester by the scene
Barry Jenkins moonlight and the Oscar
goes to
Damien Chazelle
[Applause]
[Music]
Damien Chazelle picks up his first
sermon tonight at 33 years old
CeCe's youngest in history to ever
invent director
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much this is such an honor
I just want to first thank my fellow
nominees I was absolutely honored and
floored to be in your company this year
so Barry Kenny meld and the like my eyes
are searching but know you're here
somewhere just thank you for for what
incredible filmmakers you are inspiring
me with your work every day I want to
thank the people who helped me make this
movie my crew my team everyone at
Lionsgate for taking a chance on it Ryan
and Emma for bringing it to life John
for acting alongside them and now doing
me very proud here on the stage thank
you John and I want to thank Justin who
I've known since we were both 1718 I
think Justin thank you for riding with
me on this and carrying the stream
forward and for never giving up thank
you I want to thank my family my parents
are in the crowd my sister Anna thank
you for always believing in me and
finally I want to thank Olivia my love
sitting there this is a movie about love
and I was lucky enough to fall in love
while making it and it means the world
to me that you're here sharing the twist
mate thank you thank you so much
[Applause]